[Musica]
era il 2017 e mi trovava in un letto di
ospedale che avevano appena salvato la
vita
l'unica cosa che volevo fare in quel
momento era a ritornare a fare la mia
vita precedente a fare il mio lavoro
precedente il problema era che era la
mia vita il mio lavoro ad avermi portato
in quel letto di ospedale
e si dice che nei momenti più bassi più
bui che nascono le migliori idee le
migliori opportunità ma in quel momento
non vedevo nulla chiedevo nero solo a
distanza di qualche anno capisco che
anche per me in quel letto di ospedale
stava nascendo qualcosa qualcosa di
nuovo e oggi ringrazio che
quell'episodio sia capitato l'inizio
della mia carriera professionale
perché ha cambiato totalmente il modo in
cui oggi conduco la mia vita e il lavoro
che faccio oggi vivo fuerteventura
un'isola in cui tutto scorre molto
lentamente e lavoro in uno dei luoghi
più frenetici che oggi esistono il mondo
delle cripte valute e del metaverso
immaginate il metaverso come un universo
digitale in questo universo digitale
chiamato metaverso ci sono tanti piccoli
pianeti anch'essi digitali ogni pianeta
alla sua popolazione
come ogni pianeta digitale alla sua
community on line e ogni popolazione
come ogni community online alla sua
lingua la sua cultura e la sua arte
tutto ciò che accade nel metaverso per
me è molto più importante di ciò che
accade nella mia vita reale le relazioni
che io nel metaverso sono più importanti
delle relazioni che io nella mia vita
real a fuerteventura
e probabilmente sarà così per molti di
noi e se questo può spaventarvi può
farvi ricordare matrix per esempio ma vi
devo dire che è già realtà da più di
vent'anni noi da più di vent'anni
viviamo già in una sorta di universo
digitale
la prima cosa che facciamo al mattino
anziché dare un bacio la persona accanto
a noi eletto o al nostro cane
guardiamo il telefono
la maggior parte di noi passa alle
successive otto dieci ore davanti ad un
monitor digitale a lavorare e poi la
sera non contenti accendiamo magari
anche la televisione per informarci o
per intrattenerci
le persone nate come me negli anni 90
conoscono bene questo universo digitale
ci siamo cresciuti in un universo
digitale
siamo la prima generazione di nativi
digitali
siamo la prima generazione che non ha
imparato dai libri di scuola ma imparato
dai tutorial di youtube
siamo la prima generazione che quando ha
trovato la soluzione ad un problema l'ha
condivisa con il resto del mondo con
degli sconosciuti siamo la prima
generazione di persone che ha cercato
persone affini a noi online e solo
successivamente
le ha incontrate nella vita reale e
anch'io all'età di 14 anni ho cominciato
a condividere online come immagino molti
di voi le mie passioni e quello per me è
stato il mio matrimonio con la
creatività e la creatività ancora oggi
siamo sposati è un matrimonio bellissimo
il nostro con degli alti e dei bassi nei
punti più bassi la creatività mi ha
portato in quel letto di ospedale ed è
lì che io per la prima volta ho sentito
parlare di cripto valute mi sono
cominciato ad interessare al mondo delle
cripto valute e come ogni persona che
approccio a questo nuovo mondo quasi
tutti lo approccio per fini speculativi
come fosse una scommessa dove poter
vincere un jackpot milionario ma oltre
ad essere una falsa credenza è solamente
la punta dell'iceberg della rivoluzione
che le cripto valute invece portano e
così ho passato i successivi anni a
cercare di capire come trovare un
intersezione fra questo mondo così
razionale mondo numerico con un mondo
invece così è motivo soggettivo come il
mondo creativo e artistico
fino al momento in cui ho incontrato per
la prima volta viene arti e non fungi
boltro ganz in italiano beni non
fungibili ed è una parola estremamente
complessa per descrivere qualcosa invece
di estremamente semplice
immaginate di scambiare vostra moglie
vostro marito o il vostro cane con
quello di qualcun altro
potrà andar via bene potrà andarvi male
magari
avrete un marito una moglie migliore ma
sicuramente non sarà la stessa marito la
stessa moglie perché sono beni non
fungibili anche l'arte un bene non
fungibile il quadro è un bene non
fungibile una scultura è un bene non
fungibile ma anche la fotografia è un
bene non fungibile perché se la
fotografia stampata firmata dall'artista
e numerata la numero uno parla di più
della numero due e quindi non fungibile
che cosa quindi un bene fungibile è un
bene fungibile per eccellenza sono le
banconote
supponiamo che io abbia una banconota da
10 euro e voi pure la mia è più
stropicciata della vostra la vostra a un
numero seriale sicuramente diversa dalla
mia eppure se noi ce le scambiamo
abbiamo ancora una banconata che allo
stesso valore 10 euro
noi per convenzione accettiamo che il
denaro in questo caso la banconota da
dieci euro mantenga il suo valore
nonostante cambi magari in piccoli
dettagli
scopriamo quindi che la maggior parte
delle cose intorno a noi e non fungibile
e hino football tokens benino fungibili
digitali non sono altro che immagini
video canzoni digitali con però una
piccola
peculiarità al loro interno hanno una
riga di codice invisibile
supponiamo di prendere un immagine e
all'interno di questa immagine c'è una
riga di codice invisibile che dice che
ogni qualvolta che l'immagine passa di
mano in mano diventa più grande o più
piccola oppure cambia colore però questo
è un esempio fine a se stesso
sforziamoci un po di più e proviamo ad
immaginare invece di prendere un
immagine e inserire al suo interno una
riga di codice che dice che ogni volta
che l'immagine viene venduta e passa di
proprietario in proprietario di
collezionista in collezionista il 10 per
cento della vendita finisca all'artista
si chiama royalties ed è qualcosa che
nel web negli ultimi vent'anni abbiamo
completamente dimenticato ma l'industria
creativa si è sempre basata sulle
royalties e allora questo apre un
ventaglio di nuove opportunità per tutti
i creativi
supponiamo di prendere il vostro
musicista preferito
a voi amate la sua musica è come voi
altre decine di migliaia di persone però
il vostro musicista preferito non ha
ancora una etichetta discografica
disposta a produrli
il suo nuovo album la sua arte però voi
lo amate ascoltate la sua musica quando
andate al lavoro in macchina quando fate
la doccia e quando fate l'amore
il musicista ha bisogno di denaro per
produrre la sua arte voi volete
supportare un artista che pensate che in
futuro possa scalare le classifiche e
riempire gli stadi il musicista e mette
un henner ti può essere il provino di
una sua canzone una sua fotografia un
suo video non importa l'importante è che
all'interno di questo in effetti ci sia
questa riga di codice invisibile voi
comprate le arti il musicista riceve i
fondi per produrre la sua arte voi avete
accesso a una community esclusiva di
persone che come voi hanno supportato
l'artista avete accesso a contenuti
esclusivi online e anche nella vita
reale magari potrete andare alle prove
di registrazione del suo album quale
prove prima di un concerto perché voi
siete i primi supporter di questo
artista e supponiamo che l'album
musicale creato grazie i vostri fondi
scali le classifiche delle piattaforme
musicali
e le persone e cominci ad ascoltare le
sue canzoni la canzone comincia a venir
riprodotta in radio e le persone che si
sposano la utilizzano il loro matrimonio
ogni qualvolta la canzone è riprodotta
le royalties non vanno solamente all'art
vista ma vanno la community a voi che
avete supportato l'artista dal giorno
zero
questa cosa si può applicare a tante
industrie creative all'industria
cinematografica
all'industria delle arti visive
all'industria editoriale
la domanda che un creatore su un artista
si deve fare nel 2021 non è più come
posso trarre il maggior valore dalla mia
community l'unica domanda che un artista
si deve farne al 2021 è come posso dare
il maggior valore alla mia community
valore artistico e valore economico
e allora in questi piccoli pianeti
creati da artisti e supportati da
community
nascono delle nuove economie in cui gli
incentivi sono allineati fra community e
creators e solo così si possono
raggiungere grandi obiettivi
siamo di fronte ad una nuova rivoluzione
e gli artisti sono fra i pionieri di
questa nuova tecnologia
e noi esseri umani nell'antichità ci
stavamo attorno al fuoco per raccontarci
delle storie come la storia che io vi ho
raccontato oggi a voi ed è proprio
intorno al fuoco che abbiamo creato le
prime tribù e le prime forme di società
per come le conosciamo oggi
secondo melablog chain le cripto valute
e gli han erti sono un nuovo fuoco
digitale dove sederci intorno per creare
una società digitale migliore di quella
attuale
oggi è il miglior momento nella storia
per essere un artista grazie mille